but very exciting and because you have
worked with great James judi dench yes
yes yeah what was that singer we have
about ten minutes together I think in me
mmm yeah well no it felt like longer for
me though very much is that what I know
it was it was it was yeah because I was
you know so yeah set set a Barca get and
starstruck but I was trying to be as
aware as possible and not forget
anything
remember burping just before that take I
do she blamed me explain blame me for
the bird and I was being a big serious
num he was playing a big serious non in
a big serious shabby so the burp was
amplified and yeah I got the blame I
told me mum about now we mentioned
tattoos earlier and air cuz you you're
quite inked in real life for you I've
won at earlier yeah I guess the most
famous one was fake that one on me me
bottom from glad you brought it up so
we're not mean show the picture oh that
that's it
it
it is real bossom it why are the hands
like that
I thought okay I guess I guess to imply
whatever is happening on the front was
okay
where's my guess but we didn't have
enough makeup stuff but let's stop
looking at it
we found this on my pinky we know this
is that we have to see this it's not
easy it's not